[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais du soleil des dentelles et
d'étayer
des photos de bord de mer
dans mon jardin d
je voudrais la lumière
comme en nouvelle angleterre
je veux changer d'atmosphère
[Musique]
dans mon jardin
tha
le
sur la pluie
un kiwi
gênante
et
quel
je tends
[Musique]
et
osant temps
je voudrais du fred astaire
et je voudrais toujours te plaît
je veux des jeunes est parti
de gaulle jeu que
t'embrasser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tha
cela fait 2
un kikoo
[Musique]
tu attends
les
[Musique]
qu'il est loin
la jetons
mais
la paix
on
du
non
e
[Musique]
mais
au col coa
[Musique]
pour les corps
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas parce que jamais en public que
je leur corps quand je suis seul sait
pas plus que je suis l'homme de ma vie
que j'ai cru sur un t shirt c'est pas
pour sa gueule dessus concernant
pas parce que je fais l'amour tous les
soirs je
[Musique]
il
c'est pas qu'on ait eu l'envié de faire
ce qu'on joue je ne sens pas isolé pas
parce que je te regarde dans les yeux te
dis que je m'excuse que les ou les olé
et puis c'est tout parce que je suis ça
qu'en foot je me saoule pas je suis là
je suis dans le toit
tous les mots qu'on peut
il est
[Musique]
tous les mots mon père
bon
puisque c'est ont pensé talent
et
et c'est pas parce que tu t'en faire que
tu as forcément raison ah parce que je
te connais par coeur mais c'est parce
que tu me trouves que de france je
m'engage c'est pas plus que je crie pas
pour toi angèle
allez
[Musique]
coc
c'est pas parce que je dors dehors que
je vois c'est pas pour ce que je côtoie
des stars que je vois plus les toits
c'est l'histoire que j'ai passé une
bonne soirée pas changé prise est un
moyen pour que je serais pas ici
tous les mots qu'on perd il
m
tous les mots mon père
ni dvd comme c'est compensé la langue
allez m
il
allez
[Musique]
ou encore vivre
on encore vivre en paix je dois toucher
le fond nous ferons encore être amour
rozon
[Musique]
je dois encore vivre
tu crois qu'en rue mais je dois toucher
le fun fun fun
et puis je partirai
vous plaisir
je peux encore des monts
et je baisserais les dehors du
terrain
dieu
autre s'il vous plaît c
play
ses problèmes psy
j'en veux encore
[Musique]
vos mails
chrome
je dois encore
g
quant au type
[Musique]
touche f1
le foll
en quatre ans
bon jovi
je dois en tirer
[Musique]
doit toucher
ford
et puis je parte
s'il vous plaisir
play
je vaux
non mais
[Musique]
jo
jobs
[Musique]
placez vous plaît
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
pas
m
là
la halle
je peux toucher le fond
et puis je partirai
[Musique]
de la la la
un dollar
je ne touchais
[Musique]
toiture
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
quand tu traverses la pièce
en silence que tu passes devant moi
je regarde tu échanges la lumière
tombant
des jeux
quand tu t'approches de moi ton parfois
me fait baisser les yeux
et si tu touches moment je m'arroge pour
ne pas y penser
je n'ai pas d'avis
non non
on pas d'autres amis
soit
je n'ai pas d'amis comme ça
non non non pas l'autre ami
car toi
tu comprends mieux le monde en observant
je crois je vois bleu clair
je n'ai pas trouvé la clé du mystère
mais je m'en suis approché
je n'ai pas
pas d'autres amis toi
je n'ai pas d'amis comme toi comme la
danse
malhotra mai
comme ça
[Musique]
tu es pas de moi j'ai encore beaucoup à
nous découvrir
mais dans ce tour 2 mois j'abandonne
situe dans ce tour 2 mois
[Musique]
non
à
voilà là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
toi même
[Musique]
alors
j'aime ta couleur café
tu es je veux café d'à gorge café j'aime
quand pour moi tu dans sa loge on
murmurait
tout est pas
jol du bracelet
atypique il se balance un courriel
qu'a fait que j'aime ta couleur café
carter
que j'ai tout à coup d'un quartier
[Musique]
c'est quand même faut les faire le fait
que ça fait
de te voir rouler ainsi des yeux clé des
anches je fais comme le café
rien qu'à me merlet bergame excité ce
soit la nuit sera blanche couleur café
que j'aime ta couleur café
[Musique]
que j'aime ta couleur café la motion
philosopher cinq ans que fait très vite
au passé
mais que veux tu que j'y fasse on en a
marre de café et c'est terminé pour tout
oublier
on attend que ça se tasse fait
que j'aime la couleur café
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que j'aime ta couleur café
quand pour la
[Applaudissements]
je me ta couleur café
là
qu'a fait jamais la couleur café
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
j'aurais bon parler les langues de 12
j'aurais bon accueil
[Musique]
j'aurais vous n'être pas les gens de
l'ombre
j'aurai beau être puissant donnez-moi de
l'ardennaise rassembler de l'argent
[Musique]
m
si je n'aime pas si je t'aime pas ça
sert à voir à coyron
lannoy si le même pas si je t'aime pas
ça rime à quoi
sans amour nos vies sont dérisoires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais voeckler et conquérir la terre
j'aurais beau 30 on change j'aurais vous
faire la plus belle carrière j'aurai
beau être important
[Musique]
donnez-moi le com donnez moi du temps de
10 mois de l'été venu madrid a redonné
du printemps de la beauté
donnez-moi de leur donner de l'argent
denis mauvais
tu sais même pas si je t'aime ou pas
savoir à quoi bon les amis l'avoir tué
même pas si je t'aime pas sali ma voix
sans d'amour
les sondés
[Musique]
m
ça va mais t'as pas tout
ces soirées
[Musique]
ce conte
et
donnez moi ça me donnez moi des stands
les mois de l'été
tenez moi de la retenue du grain tenait
de la beauté donnez-moi de leur donner
l'argent de l'humain ben ali elle
je m'aime pas si le thème à savoir à
quoi vous les auriez la gloire
si je n'aime pas si je t'aime pas ça
rime à quoi
sans amour nous visons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
là
[Musique]
non
m
sow
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je fus
et non noté
non
au lean on me
nous
[Musique]
harbour
lyon
oh non
non
sa galerie
et puis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes tout bon
elle est
non
[Musique]
la tiu
m
a sion
le directoire
rires
m
oui
adieu
[Musique]
à
m
deux semaines
sanaa
jeudi
et
m
[Musique]
arthur
ok
je
[Musique]
il
et d'espoir
m
je
non à dieu
[Musique]
il sourit
et
d
[Musique]
m
il
à quoi
ils perdent ans
ni le pen
mais
nulle printemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hors des sentiers battus parfois
jusqu'au sang je me suis battu passe pas
je te met au parfum sur terre battue ils
et elles sont arrivées un beau matin par
dizaines par centaines en trottinette
éclectique sourire automatique
ils ont gentrifié mon quartier huppé
risée boboïsée et lyophilisée les
derniers haricots j'ai pris cher j'ai dû
partir ici dans le loir-et-cher
provisoirement pendant cette crise
sanitaire planétaire eux ils sont
arrivés en train de l'est par bavard
dans les bars car lors de quarts schéma
moi je suis plutôt du genre nestor qui
restaure le store du restaurant pour
l'instant je suis là tu me cherches tu
as cherché noise 41 milles 180 dans le
loir et cher
mais
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d
besson nenê sol
[Musique]
et
et quand c'est nous les enfants
du plus beau des poulbots le blizzard
dans le radar carmen ton ha consona
j'arrive dans 40 salles de bal avec un
style poétique alain légal musicale hier
vous vient l'envié d'un style tobaya ici
les faits en express un plein de
tendresse et y est ça y'a tellement
c'est avec un spectaculaire si lucide
j'ai rencontré notre vie ces séances
écran en poussant parfois mais sans
souffrance et c'est pour dépasser la
qualité c'est complètement s'était fait
poisser dans ta tuque carrément dans les
dents
suivez recherche noir ça arrive et ça
les moeurs en figures libres
[Musique]
nous l'étudions je voulais qu'on je n'ai
pas fini
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]